rebosante de vida,
de plantas y animales?
En pocas palabras: la fotosíntesis.
Hace unos 2500 millones de años,
algunos viejos antepasados de los Prochlorococcus evolucionaron
para poder usar la energía solar,
absorberla
y descomponer el agua en oxígeno e hidrógeno.
Y usaron la energía química resultante
para extraer de la atmósfera el CO2, o dióxido de carbono,
y usarlo para fabricar azúcares, proteínas y aminoácidos;
todos componentes esenciales para la vida.
Y a medida que evolucionaron y se fueron multiplicando
a lo largo de millones y millones de años,
ese oxígeno se acumuló en la atmósfera.
Hasta hace unos 500 millones de años, el oxígeno en la atmósfera era suficiente
para que evolucionaran organismos más grandes,
hubo una explosión de formas de vida,
y finalmente los humanos aparecimos en escena.
Mientras esto ocurría,
algunos de esos antiguos fotosintetizadores murieron,
se comprimieron, quedaron enterrados
y se transformaron en combustible fósil,
con energía solar almacenada en sus enlaces de carbono.
Básicamente, son energía solar en forma de carbón y petróleo, bajo tierra.
Los fotosintetizadores actuales
tienen una maquinaria heredada de esos antiguos microbios
y se alimentan principalmente de todas las formas de vida en la Tierra.
Nuestro corazón late a través de la energía solar
procesada por alguna planta,
y lo que constituye nuestro organismo
es a base de CO2,
también procesado por alguna planta.
Básicamente, todos estamos hechos de energía solar y dióxido de carbono.
Básicamente somos un montón de aire caliente.
(Risas)
Como seres terrestres,
estamos muy familiarizados con las plantas terrestres:
los árboles, las hierbas, las pasturas, los cultivos.
Pero los océanos están repletos de miles de millones de animales.
¿Se han preguntado alguna vez de qué se alimentan?
Pues bien, hay una pastura invisible
de fotosintetizadores microscópicos llamados "fitoplancton"
que habitan los primeros 200 m debajo de la superficie marina
y alimentan todo el ecosistema del océano abierto.
Algunos animales viven entre ellos y los comen,
otros van hacia la superficie para comerlos de noche,
y otros permanecen en las profundidades esperando a que mueran y se asienten
y recién allí se los comen.
Este diminuto fitoplancton pesa en total
menos del 1 % de todas las plantas terrestres,
pero fotosintetizan en un año lo mismo que todas las plantas terrestres,
incluyendo la selva amazónica,
que es el pulmón del planeta.
Cada año, el fitoplancton fija 50 mil millones de toneladas de carbono
en forma de dióxido de carbono dentro de su estructura,
y alimentan al ecosistema marino.
¿Cómo puede esta diminuta cantidad de biomasa
producir la misma cantidad que todas las plantas terrestres?
Pues bien, no tienen tronco ni tallos
ni flores ni frutas que mantener.
Todo lo que tienen que hacer es crecer y dividirse, una y otra vez.
Son unas maquinitas de fotosíntesis verdaderamente económicas.
Son súper rendidoras.
Hay miles de distintas especies de fitoplancton,
de diferentes formas y tamaños,
todas de un espesor levemente inferior a un cabello humano.
Aquí vemos algunas de las especies más bellas,
como aparecen en los libros.
Las llamo las especies "carismáticas" de fitoplancton.
Y este es el Prochlorococcus.
Si, ya lo sé.
Parecen basuritas en el vidrio del microscopio.
(Risas)
Pero allí están,
y enseguida les contaré cómo son.
Pero primero les diré cómo se descubrieron.
Hace unos 38 años, trabajábamos en mi laboratorio
con una tecnología llamada "citometría de flujo"
diseñada para investigaciones biomédicas de células como las del cáncer,
pero resulta que la estábamos usando para otro propósito
que era estudiar el fitoplancton, y esa técnica era ideal para ese fin.
Funciona de la siguiente manera:
se coloca una muestra en este diminuto tubo capilar,
las células pasan por un láser en formación alineada
y a su paso van dispersando la luz según sea su tamaño
y emitiendo luz según los pigmentos que contengan,
sean naturales o teñidos.
Y la clorofila del fitoplancton,
que es verde,
emite una luz roja cuando incide una luz azul sobre ella.
Y así, durante varios años, usamos este instrumento
para estudiar nuestros cultivos de fitoplancton,
especies como esas carismáticas que les mostré antes,
para estudiar su biología celular básica.
Y durante todo ese tiempo pensábamos: ¿no sería genial
poner un instrumento como este en una embarcación,
hacer circular agua de mar
y ver qué aspecto tiene toda esa diversidad de fitoplancton?
Entonces logré conseguir
un equipo de gran tamaño para la citometría de flujo,
un láser grande y potente
que, de no funcionar en alta mar, sería retirado por la empresa que lo fabricó
y nos devolverían el dinero.
Por entonces, trabajaba con nosotros un joven científico,
Rob Olson, quien logró desarmar el equipo,
lo colocó en la embarcación, lo volvió a armar y lo llevó mar adentro.
Y funcionó de maravilla.
Fue una sorpresa, pues pensábamos que el movimiento del barco
impediría direccionar el láser,
pero realmente funcionó a la perfección.
Y así mapeamos la distribución del fitoplancton en todo el océano.
Por primera vez se lo pudo ver célula por célula, en tiempo real,
y observar lo que iba pasando; muy interesante, por cierto.
Pero un día, Rob notó unas débiles señales
que salían del instrumento.
Durante un año pensamos que era ruido en la señal
y no les dimos importancia,
pero luego vimos que, en realidad, no se comportaban como ruido.
Exhibían una serie de patrones regulares.
Resumiendo,
eran células extremadamente pequeñas,
con un espesor 100 veces menor que el de un cabello humano
que contenían clorofila.
Era el Prochlorococcus.
¿Recuerdan la imagen que les mostré?
Si se proyecta una luz azul sobre esa misma muestra,
se ve esto:
dos pequeñísimas células que emiten una luz roja.
Son los Prochlorococcus.
Son las células fotosintéticas más pequeñas y abundantes del planeta.
Al principio no sabíamos qué eran,
así que las llamábamos "las verdecitas", una denominación cariñosa.
Con el tiempo, ya supimos lo suficiente como para llamarlas Prochlorococcus,
que significa "baya verde primitiva".
Y fue entonces
cuando estas células me cautivaron de tal modo
que reorganicé todo mi laboratorio para estudiarlas de manera exclusiva,
y esa dedicación rindió sus frutos.
Me han dado una enorme satisfacción, como el estar hoy aquí.
(Aplausos)
Durante muchos años, junto con muchos otros investigadores,
estudiamos el Prochlorococcus en todos los océanos
y descubrimos que hay una gran cantidad de variedades
en el ecosistema del océano abierto.
Abundan especialmente en los llamados "giros oceánicos",
que veces reciben el nombre de "desiertos oceánicos",
pero no son desiertos precisamente.
Sus aguas azul profundo están repletas
con 100 millones de células de de Prochlorococcus por litro.
Si se los agrupa en cultivos, como hacemos nosotros,
se puede ver la bella clorofila verde que contienen.
En uno de esos tubos de ensayo hay mil millones de Prochlorococcus
y, como les comenté antes,
hay 3000 billones de billones de estas células en el planeta.
Es decir, 3000 cuatrillones,
si les interesa la conversión.
(Risas)
En total, pesan más que toda la población humana del mundo
y la fotosíntesis que realizan equivale a la de todos los cultivos terrestres.
Tienen una importancia crucial para los océanos del planeta.
Durante todos esos años en que los estudiamos
y descubrimos cuán abundantes eran,
algo nos resultó raro, y nos preguntamos: ¿cómo es posible que una sola especie
sea tan abundante en tantos hábitats distintos?
Y a medida que los aislábamos en cultivos,
comprobamos que existen distintos ecotipos.
Algunos están adaptados a la gran intensidad de luz
en la superficie del agua,
y otros están adaptados a la falta de luz en las profundidades.
Por cierto, las células que viven en el fondo de la zona iluminada
son las células más eficientes que existen para hacer la fotosíntesis.
Luego descubrimos que algunas cepas
proliferan a lo largo del ecuador,
donde las temperaturas son más altas,
y otras que se desarrollan mejor en temperaturas menores
hacia el norte y hacia el sur.
Y así, cuanto más las investigábamos, más diversidad encontrábamos,
y nos decíamos: vaya, ¿cuánto más diversas pueden ser?
Y en aquella época, pudimos secuenciar sus genomas,
investigar en su interior y conocer su estructura genética.
Y así hicimos la secuenciación genética de nuestros cultivos
y además, con la citometría de flujo,
logramos aislar células individuales de su ambiente natural
y secuenciar sus genomas individuales.
De este modo, pudimos secuenciar cientos de Prochlorococcus.
Y si bien cada célula contiene unos 2000 genes,
la décima parte del genoma humano,
a medida que secuenciamos más y más,
descubrimos que tienen tan solo 1000 genes en común.
Los otros 1000 de cada cepa individual
se extraen de una enorme reserva genética
y reflejan el ambiente particular donde la célula podría haber prosperado,
no solo la intensidad de la luz o de la temperatura,
sino la presencia de nutrientes que pueden limitarlos,
como el nitrógeno, el fósforo y el hierro.
Reflejan el hábitat del que proceden.
Pensémoslo de esta manera:
Si cada célula es un teléfono inteligente
y las aplicaciones son los genes.
El móvil viene de fábrica
con algunas aplicaciones que no se pueden borrar.
En un iPhone, las mantenemos presionadas y no se mueven, no aparece la "x".
Aunque queramos eliminarlas, no podremos.
Son como...
(Risas)
Son como los genes básicos del Prochlorococcus.
Son la esencia del teléfono.
Pero hay una gran cantidad de aplicaciones disponibles
para adaptar el dispositivo a nuestro estilo de vida y entorno particulares.
Si viajan con frecuencia, instalarán aplicaciones para viajeros;
si se dedican a las finanzas, usarán aplicaciones de negocios
o, si son como yo, tendrán muchas aplicaciones meteorológicas
en la esperanza de que alguna les pronostique buen tiempo.
(Risas)
Estos dos días en Vancouver me enseñaron
que no necesito una aplicación meteorológica sino un paraguas.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Así como el móvil refleja nuestra rutina,
nuestro estilo de vida,
la lectura del genoma de una célula de Prochlorococcus
nos indicará los problemas que hay en su medio ambiente.
Es como leer su agenda,
en la que figuran no solo sus actividades durante el día o la semana,
sino también su historia evolutiva.
Luego de secuenciar cientos de estas células,
podemos ahora proyectar
el tamaño de la reserva genética
de la "federación de Prochlorococcus", como la llamamos.
Es como un superorganismo.
Y resulta que esas proyecciones
indican que hay en total 80 000 genes.
Es cuatro veces el tamaño del genoma humano.
Y esa diversidad de reservas genéticas
les permite dominar esas vastas extensiones de océano
y mantener su estabilidad
año tras año.
Por eso, cuando fantaseo con el Prochlorococcus,
probablemente más de lo recomendado,
(Risas)
los imagino flotando en el mar,
haciendo su tarea,
manteniendo el planeta,
alimentando a los animales.
Pero, inevitablemente, también pienso
en la obra maestra que son,
producto de una delicada adaptación en años de evolución.
Con 2000 genes,
son capaces de hacer lo que la inventiva del hombre
aún no logró hacer.
Pueden tomar la energía solar, el CO2,
y convertirlo en energía química en forma de carbono orgánico,
almacenando esa energía solar en enlaces de carbono.
Si pudiéramos saber a ciencia cierta cómo lo hacen,
podría ser la inspiración de diseños
que nos permitan reducir la dependencia de combustibles fósiles,
y así vuelvo al punto de partida.
Los combustibles fósiles enterrados y que nosotros quemamos
tardaron millones de años en estar bajo tierra,
incluyendo los antepasados del Prochlorococcus,
y los estamos quemando en un abrir y cerrar de ojos
en términos de la escala geológica.
El dióxido de carbono es cada vez más abundante en la atmósfera.
Es un gas de efecto invernadero.
Los océanos empiezan a calentarse.
La pregunta, entonces, es: ¿qué efecto tendrá todo esto
en mis Prochlorococcus?
Quizá piensen que mis Prochlorococcus tienen las horas contadas,
pero en realidad no es así.
Las proyecciones indican que proliferarán con el calentamiento marino
y aumentarán un 30 % para el 2100.
¿Es motivo para celebrar?
Pues bien, me alegra por Prochlorococcus, claro está,
(Risas)
pero no por el planeta.
Hay ganadores y perdedores
en esta tarea que hemos asumido a nivel global
y se especula que entre los perdedores
estarán algunos de los fitoplancton más grandes, los carismáticos,
que serán menos abundantes,
y son los que alimentan el zooplancton del que se alimentan los peces
que nos gusta pescar.
Si bien el Prochlorococcus es mi musa desde hace 35 años,
existe una gran cantidad de otros microbios
que ayudan a mantener el planeta.
Allí están,
listos y esperando a que los investiguemos y puedan contarnos su historia también.
Gracias.
Aplausos.